You're dishonest and a hypocrite here,
Trent. And I say this in love, brother.
In love. I got to call you out. Even
Paul called Peter hypocrite, so don't
think you're better than Peter. You and
I are not good enough to carry Peter's
or Paul's sandals. But here's where I'm
going to call you out. Stay in your
lane, Trent. Stay in your lane.
Or to get out sinful wrath and anger.
However, some terminally online people
will say you can be a good Christian and
still go scorched earth on your
opponents because Jesus whipped the
money changers in the temple. But the
Bible doesn't say Jesus whipped anyone.
Now watch.
I want to be gracious to this brother
cuz I don't hate this brother.
I want you to see the shameless
butchering of John 2. Notice he said,
"Jesus didn't whip anyone." At
best, that's an argument from silence.
See, guys? May the spirit purge us in
his purifying fire. Purify us in the
name of Jesus Christ. Save me from error
and pride. Not be the thing I hate. Work
through me to show you how not to
interpret scripture. How to interpret
scripture and go beyond rhetoric.
This is If this was a Muslim saying it,
I would say, "You're a dishonest Muslim
and a Bible pervert."
You're arguing from silence. Notice what
he said. "It doesn't say that Jesus
whipped anyone." But now watch how it's
going to backfire against him. I want
you to see.
John 2:14-15 says, "In the temple, he
found those who were selling oxen and
sheep and pigeons and the money changers
at their business. And making a whip of
cords, he drove them all with the sheep
and oxen out of the temple. And he
poured out the coins of the money
changers and overturned their tables."
Jesus is described as overturning the
tables after the money changers left the
temple, not throwing tables on top of
them. And no, by the way, that's not my
position. If he's saying there are
Christians who say overturn the tables
on them,
all right, that's not what I'm saying.
But did Jesus use physical force? Did he
exert physical force?
And was Jesus confrontational
that he wasn't afraid to enter in a mob
and use physical force to reprimand
them. That's the point, Trent. But
Trent, it's not going to look good for
you cuz I want you to see what he does
here.
And the clause he drove them all with
the sheep and oxen out of the temple
isn't the best translation of this
passage. That's because the common Greek
words for with are not in this part of
the passage. The passage literally says,
"And having made a whip of cords, all he
drove out from the temple both No.
both sheep and oxen. Guys,
if a Muslim had done this, I'd say,
"What a wicked, dishonest distortion of
scripture." But for the sake of charity,
I have to be Christ-like to him.
Okay, I want you to go full screen.
He says the word with is not in the
text.
But now, guys, tell me.
I want you to use common sense.
When John tells us he made a whip of
cords and he drove them out
and
cords, all he drove out from the temple.
And having made a whip of cords, all he
drove out from the temple.
Both sheep and oxen.
Okay.
Is now Trent saying
that what he drove out are sheep and
oxen?
So, Trent is saying
that Jesus was being physically violent
to sheep and oxen?
Is that what he's saying?
What is he saying here?
He's okay with, even though he wants to
deny anyone got whipped, but he just
said, "It didn't say Jesus whipped
anyone."
So, are you telling me
that John just wrote something
superfluously, that Jesus made a whip of
cords because he had nothing better to
do because he didn't do anything with
the whip of cords?
Because the text doesn't say he drove
out anyone, that means it didn't even
say he drove out animals if we go with
this exegesis, right?
Right?
If we go with his logic.
So, are you saying, Trent, that he just
made a whip of cords, but he didn't
drive out anyone, but now you're saying
he did drive out someone, the animals?
But why would he drive out the animals?
What did the animals do?
So, he's going to drive out the animals
who are innocent and guiltless, but not
those
who were
abusing God's house.
See what he just did?
You You understand, right? He goes,
"Well, the whip is not particularly a
good translation." But that's why
commentators
decipher from the context that the band
of cords were made not solely to drive
out animals, but to drive out their
owners along with their animals, so they
will supply it for for clarity's sake.
Now, here, I'm going to test my theory.
I'm going to test my theory
right here. What am I going to do?
I'm going to test my theory.
I do Again, man, I I I haven't looked at
this in a while, but I want to see
something.
I want to see how many translations
Hold on. Let me go back here.
Sorry, guys. Let me go back here.
It would reveal a reckless, lawless
spirit incompatible with Christ's
and overturned their tables. Jesus is
described as overturning the tables
after the money changers left the
temple, not throwing tables on top of
them. And the clause he drove them all
with the sheep and oxen out of the
temple isn't the best translation of
this passage. That's because the common
Greek words for with are not in this
part of the passage. The passage
literally says, "And having made a whip
of cords, all he drove out from the
Okay.
I'm going to just here it's I had done
this last time, but I'm going to do it
again. I'm going to do it again.
Let me go to John 2:14.
He found in the temple courts those who
were selling oxen, sheep, and doves, and
the money changers sitting at tables.
Okay.
Tables, right? So, we're going to go to
verse 15. That's the verse he was
looking at. So, he made a whip of cords
and drove them all out of the temple
courts with the sheep and the oxen.
Now, we're going to see how many
translations have to supply it. Let's
see. Sorry about that. Let me just see.
Now, a Muslim did this, I'd say the
Muslim was disowned, but it was a
brother in Christ, and I'll say he
doesn't know any better.
All right. And when he had made a
scourge of small cords, he drove all
them out. This is again an illustration
of what people do when they want to make
the Bible agree with their assumptions,
their presuppositions, their traditions,
their beliefs, and biases. He's very
He's now guilty of doing what he accuses
Protestants and others of doing, and we
all do it. All right, with the sheep and
the oxen. Okay.
American Standard Version, "And he made
a scourge of cords and cast out cast all
out of the both the sheep and the oxen."
All right, this is ambiguous.
Cast out here, they're giving the
impression it's the sheep and oxen. All
right.
With the sheep and the oxen, but watch
what Origen's going to do to him.
Here, both the sheep and the oxen. All
right.
Okay.
So far, some are saying it's the sheep
and oxen, but remember
he drove them all out of the temple and
the sheep and the oxen. Oh, this one
saying it's not just animals cuz you
have to supply
a preposition something to clarify,
right? Now, sorry about the noise
outside.
After making a whip out of cords, he
drove everyone out of the temple with
their sheep and oxen. Yep.
After making a whip out of cords, he
drove everyone out of the temple with
their sheep and oxen.
He made a whip from ropes and chased
them all out of the temple including the
cattle and sheep. You see how desperate
this guy is?
To make the Bible fit with his
temperament
and make the Bible fit
with his view of who Jesus was?
You see what he just did?
All right.
You guys seeing it, right?
All right, let's see. He made a whip
from cords, drove them all off of the
grounds, the sheep and cattle as well.
As well, so it's not just sheep and
oxen.
With their sheep and oxen. Now, this one
little more ambiguous, both the sheep
and oxen.
And the sheep and oxen. All right, Dewey
Rames
agrees Jesus drove them out with their
animals.
The sheep also and the oxen. So, is he
saying Dewey Rames is a bad translation?
Maybe. Maybe cuz he's he has been
influenced by liberal critical
scholarship.
ERV, then he forced all these men and
the sheep and cattle to leave the temple
area.
Interesting.
So, he wants to go to the Greek because
he can't handle the fact that just
because a preposition or some word is
not used there
that somehow means he didn't use the
whip of cords to drive out humans, but
he would have us believe he drove out
animals.
Okay. So, God
in the flesh
drives out animals forcefully, but not
human beings.
And that's supposed to be
somehow less offensive?
Right? Less offensive? Let me close this
cuz the noise in the back.
So, he's okay as a Catholic for Jesus
driving out animals.
Physically driving out animals as long
as he doesn't do it to human beings.
Right?
You understand where he's going with
this, right?
Really, Trent? Come on, man.
But, hold on. Let's see. Let's see. I'm
not going to belabor this point cuz I
want to show you what he did with
Origen.
And he can say what he wants, do what he
wants. Trent, stay in your lane,
brother. Stay away from the issue of
science.
Stay away from evolution, creation. Stay
away from Genesis. Stay away from these
issues of how to treat people. Stay in
your lane. Don't criticize us and we
don't criticize you and put you in your
place, brother.
All right?
ESV
He drove them all out of the temple with
the sheep and oxen.
Exegetical Bible, Jesus made a whip out
of cords and forced all of them, both or
even has to say with. See, they have to
be fair. Because you can't let your bias
affect
how the text should be understood
interpreted because you have a hippy
Jesus, who's a lovey-dovey Jesus, who
would never use physical force.
Right?
With the sheep and oxen. Am I boring you
guys here? With the sheep and cows. This
is again warning you do not idolize me
or him.
He has his biases and he'll misread the
scripture in light of his biases.
Right?
So, he made a whip from cords and drove
all the animals out of the temple. Now,
you see here?
Now, this is
clearly not what the Greek says, but
nonetheless
they don't want a Jesus who exerts
physical force.
All right.
With their sheep and oxen.
With the sheep and cattle.
Including the sheep and the cattle. Man,
they all butchered the Bible, but Tren
Horn is right. You're right, brother.
You know, you made a believer out of us.
Here, Phillips, J.B. Phillips.
Watch here.
So, he made a rough whip out of rope and
drove the whole lot of them, sheep and
cattle as well.
Right?
And even when it says and the sheep and
the oxen doesn't mean only the animals,
along with the sheep and the oxen. Even
and means drove them out and the sheep
and the oxen, right?
That's what the and means. He drove them
out and the sheep and the oxen.
And means it was the humans and their
animals with the sheep and oxen.
Right?
Both the sheep and oxen would imply it's
only the animals.
Chase them all out and drove out the
sheep and oxen. Hmm.
Man, they all got it wrong, huh?
With the sheep and oxen.
Right?
Now, this one I love.
Jesus put together a whip of out of
strips of leather and chased them out of
the temple stampeding the sheep and
cattle.
All right.
Mounce.
William Mounce, another scholar of the
Greek New Testament. So, he made a whip
out of cords and drove them all out of
the temple including the sheep and the
cattle. This is one of the most pathetic
and weakest arguments from Tren Horn.
It's so bad
it's beneath him and his scholarship.
Right?
It's beneath him and his scholarship.
You see how bad it is, guys?
I had to adjust this because I want you
not to idolize any of us. Sad sadly,
there are hornyans who will idolize this
guy and can do no wrong and because they
don't like rough personalities, will
just bend over backwards to agree with
him and demonize me and others.
You cannot love any of us more than you
love the commitment to truth and Christ.
Yeah, I sin. Yeah, I I don't practice
what I preach perfectly. Yeah, but it
doesn't mean that's because you don't
like my personality, but you like Chad
cuz he's so sweet and nice and
lovey-dovey, that means he's right. No,
that's not true. That's not the case at
all.
All right.
Name of God, he made a whip from small
ropes and threw everyone with their
sheep and cattle out of the temple yard.
See how pathetic that argument was?